you know much i enjoyed nobody uh i know  you guys are developing a sequel  what what exactly is happening with with  a sequel to that film oh i think  everyone's really excited about it  everyone involved is like you know full  steam ahead we um  are in the script process and i think um  you know we had so much fun making that  you know  you know kelly and i had a blast the  actors had a blast um the studio  loved the results and um  it's happening i mean i think it's  happening um  as fast as we can make it happen  well you know sometimes people talk  about sequels and like they never  actually happen do you think it's like  actually going to happen  [Laughter]  yes i do  i do because there are these certain  journeys that you go on and um they're  just undeniable experiences for the  people involved and that was one of them  and i think all of us want to go back  and and play in that universe and and we  want to see bob you know  bring that character to life again  you